it's probably too shallow for a great
way to even consider swimming in that
direction why are shark movies so bad hi
my name is Imani Weber Schultz I'm a
shark scientist I study shark morphology
today we're going to be looking at shark
attacks in movies and judging how real
they are
I don't even know who came up with the
idea that you should hit a shark on the
nose to get away from them in general if
you're being attacked by anything you
should probably be hitting them in
whatever places you can to get them away
from you however shark noses aren't as
weak as I think we make them out to be
they're overlaid with some skills that
are basically meant for abrasion
strength so if they're poking around
trying to figure out what something is
their nose is protecting them from
getting harmed
they don't necessarily have to eat as
often as movies portray them to shark
digestion actually takes a really long
time whereas us as people we have a
really fast metabolism and so we're
eating all the time sharks have a lot
slower versions of that once they get
enough in a meal they'll just swim
around and let all of that Digest
thank you
so people are not a natural food item
for sharks and so they aren't
necessarily swimming around the ocean
thinking oh where's the person for me to
eat often they're really just looking
for what their favorite meal is which we
do know that sharks have preferences for
what food they're consuming often when
they bite people it's a curiosity bite
meaning they just want to know what we
are
they actually did a pretty decent job of
making Bruce the shark look somewhat
correct sharks have between five and
seven gill slits great whites have five
and in this movie they did give him five
which admittedly made me happy one of
the biggest things that they got wrong
is his size though in the film he's
around 25 feet Which is far larger than
the largest great whites that we know
about in general females are the bigger
of the two of males and females and they
get to be around 16 feet as a total
maximum length so Bruce is about 10 feet
larger than the average great white
shark that we know of this movie was
really influential in creating this
public perception of sharks that they
are man-eaters and then the subsequent
Terror that people felt after watching
it there was a really poor view on what
sharks are and how important they are to
the ecosystem now I think we're kind of
bouncing back from this you see a lot of
people realizing how important they are
to this planet I'm gonna give this a 5
out of 10 purely because they did an
okay job with the body of Bruce and
because I really appreciate the amount
of Gill switch they gave him oh how
Dory are you okay
one of the things that this movie did do
well is you can actually see the blood
from Dory go into Bruce's nose we have a
common misconception that sharks can
just smell a drop of blood from a mile
away when in reality their noses
actually work very similar to ours in
that they have to get a particle of that
blood actually enter their nose for them
to realize that it's there smell is not
necessarily the thing that sharks are
using to move about their environment
and observe it but one of the advantages
that they have is their lateral line
system which allows them to sense
vibrations in the water so if they're
within a certain amount of feet of say
an injured fish they can actually feel
the vibrations from that fish flopping
around and turn towards that and think
oh that might be an injured thing that I
can eat they have sight they do have
ears they can hear they're using all of
these different senses together
just a boy
so sharks do not go in a frenzy when
they smell blood but they do get curious
so often they will completely turn to
where that scent of blood came from and
swim towards it in general they are
opportunistic feeders so they don't want
to expend more energy than they need to
for the food that they're going to eat
in this example a clownfish and Dory
would not actually be a sufficient meal
for a great white shark like Bruce so he
wouldn't even be putting any effort into
trying to capture them he would be more
interested in say something like a seal
which would offer him an easier meal and
also give him a lot more in terms of
energy
so there are a couple of different types
of omnivorous sharks my favorite example
is the Bonnet head which actually eats
sea grass in addition to crabs you also
have the biggest sharks in the ocean
such as whale sharks basking sharks and
megamouth sharks these are all filter
feeders so they essentially just swim
with their mouth open or suction water
in to then filter food out and usually
this food ends up being things like
Plankton or shrimp but of the sharks in
the scene which are the great white
shark the short fin Mako and the
Hammerhead none of these sharks are
omnivorous or vegetarian I'm going to
give this a 4 out of 10.
[Music]
I'm not convinced that these sharks
aren't real sharks they are like
unreasonably realistic down to like the
tag that's on the dorsal fin and also
that pre-dorsal Ridge that you can see
on the top of the head of the tiger
shark one of the Dead giveaways for
knowing if a shark is in fact a tiger
shark is those tiger-like gray stripes
that you can see on the side of their
body just like you can see in this scene
the scene is extremely unrealistic they
wouldn't be smelling the smoke that's in
the air and there wouldn't be smoke
under the water
[Music]
it's not unexpected for an attack to be
from a tiger shark they're probably in
the top five sharks to be considered to
be more dangerous to humans than others
they eat essentially anything people
have found license plates in their
stomach which I think is crazy so in the
scene Sean Connery is swimming away if
the tiger shark wanted to eat a prey
item especially someone like a person
who is not built to be swimming in a
water environment you wouldn't be able
to get away but in the scene it's
probably slightly more realistic to a
shark that was just curious just
following you around trying to kind of
figure out what you are and so this
tiger shark isn't actually exerting that
much energy in this probably because
it's not actually that interested I'm
gonna give this a 6 out of 10 because
the sharks are actually real
okay
this is one of the ones where this shark
swims by and there's like eight gill
slits on this thing and it drives me
bonkers this is supposed to be a
Megalodon shark they are a prehistoric
shark so they are in fact extinct
despite this movie making you believe
that they might maybe somewhere be real
this shark is okay in terms of
anatomically correct they make the shark
around 75 feet long although newer
research is showing that megalodons were
probably closer to around 60 feet
wow
yes this is what real shark Cinema is
there is actually no way to get out of
it and they're also not normally glass
she's like doing like a photo shoot down
there with that amount of light I'm
going to try to hit it in the eye
she's aiming for the eye probably a good
idea to aim for the softest spots on the
body of anything that is attacking you
structurally the weakest spot on a shark
in terms of ability to actually give
them injury and be somewhat catastrophic
to them is their stomach because their
stomach is a lot less protected than the
upper part of their body which has a
very big layer of muscle and tissue
their stomach is somewhat lined but then
right past that wall you have all of
their essential organs however
sharks have been shown to sometimes be
able to swim around with holes in their
body depending on where it is assuming
they don't lose any of those essential
organs because sharks are crazy
[Music]
sharks are not that crazy about dragging
their prey along to eat it they will
typically take a big bite and shake
their head to create this like gouging
motion to get a chunk off and then
swallow it and they also probably
wouldn't be trying this hard to get a
small piece of prey like a human I'm
gonna rate this as a one out of ten top
tier movie
this is supposed to be a great white
shark and if you look at the depth that
Blake Lively is surfing at it's probably
too shallow for a great way to even
consider swimming in that direction
juvenile great whites do go into
shallower water because they're smaller
so if you're smaller you can go into
shallower water but really large great
whites have a tendency to hang out
offshore or in way deeper waters purely
because they're too big to actually swim
into shallower Waters in 2021 there were
around 73 unprovoked shark attacks
worldwide and roughly 50 to 51 percent
of those were people who were surfing or
on boards because you are like a large
form that has things that look like
flippers or fins hanging off the side of
you I could see that being something
that they might confuse but whether or
not they actually confuse you for
another prey item or they're just
curious as to what you are is hard to
say
no
disgusting
first of all absolutely no one would be
surfing near a whale carcass because
dead mammals smell terrible
secondly a great white would absolutely
go after a dead whale carcass as opposed
to a person because they don't have to
expend any energy for it it's basically
free food I'm gonna give this scene a
one out of ten
so the fin out of the water Trope is
mostly a movie thing obviously the
dorsal fin is the highest point on their
body so if they're swimming near the
surface then you're going to see that
dorsal fin but it's largely unrealistic
that sharks are regularly doing this
at least that part of this scene is
somewhat correct
great white sharks do breach all the way
out of the water for a very short period
of time before they re-enter sharks that
breach in general it's usually during
feeding however breaching out of the
water to reach a person on a boat is
very unrealistic great whites when
they're breaching often they will swim
relatively slowly when they're trying to
figure out if this is a prey item that
they actually want to eat and then in
that last couple of feet that is when
they will swim really fast and that's
how they end up breaching the water this
is hugely energetically costly though so
they aren't actually breaching as often
as the media portrays them to be
it's probably somewhat unlikely that a
shark injured to the extent that this
one is would keep coming back for the
same prey item however there are sharks
that will eat prey that may or may not
cause them harm a really good example of
this is Hammerheads they have been found
to have Ray barbs or The Stingers lodged
into their mouth because they love
eating them and it apparently does not
bother them to just be swimming around
with a bunch of spikes sticking out of
their face I'm giving this a 0 out of
10. I think the whole clip is ridiculous
it's called photophores
that means
cells that light up the cookie cutter
sharks they do show that cookie cutters
by luminesce that's a really cool fact
about them and this idea of
bioluminescence is through the use of
photophores as said in this scene where
they have cells that essentially light
up along their body and cookie cutter
sharks will do this on purpose to
attract maybe even a larger predator or
a prey item for them
they actually did a pretty decent job on
both describing what a cookie cutter
shark is and showing how they feed they
do essentially bite the prey that they
want to eat and then rapidly spin off
which is how you get that cookie cutter
bite mark they also did a decent job of
showing their body they do have that
really large eye because they generally
live in habitats that are a lot deeper
in the ocean and so there's not as much
natural light going down there you know
what else is weird about them they
swallow their own teeth
I love this fact cookie cutter sharks
live in a nutrient poor environment and
so getting all the nutrients that they
want can be a lot harder to come by and
so they will swallow the entire bottom
row of their teeth to then recycle that
calcium so this is a shark jaw sharks
because they lose their teeth so often
they probably do on accident consume
some of their teeth but in general the
cookie cutter shark is the one that we
know of that does this on purpose their
jaw doesn't look like this the bottom
row of teeth is actually all fused
together so it's just one big tooth with
a bunch of spikes at the top and that
whole bar of teeth will then fall and
they will eat that and retake the
calcium out of that
they show them eating in a pack in this
specific scene we don't generally think
of them as being pack animals we usually
think of them as being more solitary
they are also more of a deep sea shark
and so us learning about their social
habits is actually a lot harder than if
we were doing say a shark that's at the
surface quite often cookie cutter sharks
have been known to bite people as a
smaller shark they're pretty much going
to be biting whatever they can find to
try to get nutrients from generally
speaking these bites are not as fatal as
say if you got bit by a great white
shark but often these happen people go
out swimming in the ocean at dawn or
dusk that is when cookie cutters come up
to feed I'm gonna give this a 5 out of
10 because I'm really happy that they
told everybody that they swallowed their
teeth and that they showed that they buy
luminesce
coming the water is pretty common which
is just putting essentially ground up
bait into the water this is a thing that
people do use especially if you go on a
shark tourism boat or go cage diving in
this case they're putting what looks
like a lot of blood into the water
chumming in general is not great for
sharks there have been studies that have
showed that if you are a tourism boat or
in a touristy area where shark tourism
is a really big part of your economy
then chumming can actually teach the
Sharks to come near when they hear
things like boat motors and then start
to associate that boat motor or people
with food
foreign
in general if you have to swim in a
direction going through the area where
food may or may not be for a predator is
not good advice it's quite unrealistic
that if someone got bitten in the
abdomen that they wouldn't just bleed
out and die immediately there is no such
thing as a soft
grip if you're in the mouth of a shark
and so they would have probably just
been bleeding a lot more and or had full
chunks bitten out of them
oh my gosh they put the wow
so in this scene you can see all these
little black dots around the underside
of its nose these are called ampullive
lorenzini which allows sharks to detect
electricity and they use this to
essentially just sense electricity in
the ocean so when we like tense our
muscles that creates little tiny amounts
of electricity and they can actually
sense that and I am in shock that they
put that on the shark in this movie I'm
giving this a 4 out of 10 because I like
that they included the ampulive
laurenzini
the Sharks circling this raft that is
pretty common because sharks are curious
just like us so if they want to know
what something is they will kind of
circle around to just keep some eyes on
it maybe try to get some smells and
figure out what it is a really good
example of this is people who dive with
Oceanic whitetips they're quite curious
in terms of sharks and so they will kind
of come up to you and swim around and be
looking at you and maybe trying to smell
what you are
whether or not you should be splashing
to get away from them or not is kind of
up in the air but in general splashing
will draw attention to you in the ocean
because they can feel the vibrations of
you swimming away
foreign
this is pretty common with sharks they
will eat each other despite popular
belief sharks are not all apex predators
a lot of them fill that middle part of
the food pyramid which makes them a
mesop predator so if you are a larger
shark it's quite common for you to eat
smaller sharks I'm gonna give this scene
a four out of 10.
so these are supposed to be mako sharks
and they look slightly more close to a
great white although makos in general
often are considered to just be great
white shark looking but smaller they did
a pretty decent job on the teeth though
you can see them kind of jutting out of
their jaw they recognize that gun
shocks did not swim backwards they can't
in general sharks cannot swim backwards
the main reason for this is that they
don't actually have a locomotor motion
that would move them backwards so if we
were walking backwards we're just moving
our feet and pushing in a backwards
Direction they don't have something near
or at the front of their body that would
provide thrust to let them move
backwards I'm gonna give this a 2 out of
10 because I feel bad giving another
film a one out of ten my favorite shark
movie is shark night because I know how
unrealistic it is I just end up laughing
the whole time and also Jaws because
Jaws is just the OG shark movie if you
liked this video feel free to click the
link above